Well,
one thing we don't talk about is that
it's sort of hard to talk about this.
Our,
our minds have these kinds of back
doors.
There's just,
there's kind of,
if you're human and you wake up and you
open your eyes,
there is a certain set of dimensions to
your experience that can be manipulated.
When I was a kid,
I was a magician.
And you learn all about these limits.
You know that short term memory is about
this long and there's different reaction
times.
And if you ask people certain questions
in certain ways,
you can control the answer.
And this is just the structure of being
human.
To be human means that you are
persuadable in every single moment.
I mean,
the thing about magic as an example is
that magic works on everybody sleight of
hand,
right?
It doesn't matter what language you
speak,
it doesn't matter how intelligent you
are.
It's not about what someone knows,
it's about how your mind actually works.
So knowing this,
it turns out that there's this whole
playbook of persuasive techniques that
actually I learned when I was at the
Stanford persuasive technology lab.
And that most people in Silicon Valley
and the tech industry learned as ways of
getting your attention.
So one example is we are all vulnerable
to social approval.
We really care what other people think
of us.
So for example,
you know when you upload a new photo,
a new profile photo of yourself on
facebook,
uh,
that's a moment where our mind is very
vulnerable to knowing what other people
think of my new profile photo.
And so when we get new likes on our
profile photo facebook knowing this
could actually message me and say,
Oh you have new likes on your profile
photo and we it knows that will be
vulnerable to that moment because we all
really care about when we're tagged in a
photo or when we have a new profile
photo.
And the thing is that they control the
dial,
the technology companies control the
dial for when and how long your profile
photo shows up on other people's news
feeds so they can orchestrate it so that
other people more often end up liking
your profile photo over a delayed period
of time,
for example.
So that you end up having to more
frequently come back and see what the
new lights are.
Right?
And the problem is that they don't do
this because they're evil.
They do it because again,
they're in this race for our attention.
And we should also ask,
is that necessarily such a bad thing if
they're orchestrating it so that other
people,
uh,
like my,
my photo,
I mean that might feel good to me,
but so we have to have a new
conversation about as these technology
companies use these techniques,
these vulnerabilities in our minds,
uh,
when is that actually aligned in good
for us?
What does that ethical,
when is that,
uh,
honest one?
Is that fair?
And what does that dishonest and unfair
because they're actually manipulating
our minds in a way that doesn't add up
to our spending our time.
Well,
uh,
on the screen.
Well,
so another vulnerability in our mind is
something called a variable schedule
reward.
And that's like a slot machine in Las
Vegas.
It turns out that slot machines make
more money in the United States then
baseball,
movies and theme parks combined.
People become addicted to slot machines.
I think it's two to three times faster
than any other kind of gambling in a
casino.
So it's,
it's insane.
And why is that?
Because it's very simple.
You just pull a lever and sometimes you
get a reward as you know,
and sometimes you don't.
And the more random it is and the more
variable it is,
the more addictive it becomes.
And the thing is that that turns our
phone into a slot machine because every
time we check our phone,
we're playing the slot machine to see
what did I get right?
Every time that we,
um,
check our email,
we're,
we're playing the slot machine to see
what did I get?
Did I get invited to an interview at big
think or did I just get another
newsletter?
Right?
Um,
or if you're on a tent dating site like
tinder and when you're swiping,
each swipe is you're playing the slot
machine to see,
did I get a match?
I'm playing the slot machine to see,
And the problem is that this dynamic,
these variable schedule rewards or the
slot machine mechanic is so powerful but
it's the,
it's the best thing and addicting people
and putting you in the zone.
Um,
one of the original designers of the
facebook newsfeed told me that,
um,
the thing that made the news feed work
at the very,
very,
very beginning back in 2006,
um,
was in part a hardware innovation.
And I looked at her and I said,
what do you mean?
And she said it was actually the scroll
wheel on a mouse because with the scroll
wheel on the mouse,
your hand never had to leave its resting
position.
You just scroll to see the next thing
and the,
because before that you had to click on
the down button or drag,
move your mouse and drag the Arrow down.
It's called the page.
That way when you don't,
when you can take your two fingers on a
track pad and do this or you can just
scroll on a scroll wheel.
It just means your hand never has to
leave its resting position.
And it's more like a slot machine.
You can just keep swiping and playing.
Just like in Vegas where there's the
button right there.
They actually changed it.
In fact,
it used to be a lever and now it's just
a button.
And in Vegas,
because it founds,
its easier just to get people to,
to see if they get a match this way.
So how much on our phones when we use
our technology,
instagram is like a slot machine.
What's going to come next on the feeds?
You know,
snapchat is a slot machine.
Each time you see the red notifications
and you don't know what's behind it,
you're playing the slot machine when you
click on it to see what did I get right.
And so it's,
it's sprinkled all throughout these
products because it's a very compelling
way of getting people's attention.